so red flag number 14
she was a sugar baby what is that
sugar baby only fans Creator
um any any one of those things she's
basically selling her sexuality to other
guys for money and it's usually simps or
older guys you know with cash that want
to either want to take care of her or
want to pay for her company
um
it's prostitution you know there's no
other way to State it it's she's
basically a hooker
um and if you want to invite a woman
like that into your life then don't
expect to have a a simple Pleasant life
you're you're going to be dealing with
baggage you're going to be dealing with
problems if a woman's chosen to sell
herself and
you know they they try to justify it in
any number of ways well I'm a digital
Creator no you sell pictures of your
butthole on only fans to nerds every
single month and that's how you make a
living like this is you're going to
argue that you're a digital Creator or
it's or or it's something of that nature
um
no man realistically wants photographs
and
a footprint out there of a woman that's
demonstrated that she's not uh private
you know in some regard or percents uh
it's it's disgusting and men are
inherently disgusted by it so it's you
know one of the telltale signs is a girl
that's been on sugar dating sites or
hasn't only fans
um not good bad sign for sure
yeah so essentially women who are taking
cash for showing their ass
cash for ass that's it prostitution
great way to put it okay red flag number
pathological liars and so I you know you
use that word pathological that means
it's an illness of sorts that this
person needs to lie uh about everything
is that right yeah I mean pathological
Liars are so dangerous Elliot because
I mean look if you're gonna invite a
woman in your life again girlfriend wife
children you know whatever path you
happen to choose you want a woman that
you can trust that you can rely on that
that you can
you can uh
basically open yourself up to because at
the end of the day if you're going to be
with her for a long period of time you
need that kind of partnership and if
she's she's going to reveal herself to
be a pathological liar that's a major
danger zone man I mean it could be a
danger zone from an early point where
she says oh don't worry I'm on birth
control just go inside me I mean she's
not and she might be trying to trap you
yeah uh it you know what the the very
first time that I came across this I was
quite young this is my first girlfriend
because I was 19 I used to ride a
motorcycle at that time and
um because she wanted to compete with me
in a sense or in her regard she said
well I have a motorcycle too but it's at
my mom's house her parents were uh
divorced and I said oh okay well that's
interesting so when are we going to go
riding together like why don't we go get
it so we can go for a rip and there was
always a reason why it's not available
it's in storage uh my mom's boyfriend uh
moved it to another building something
for months and then something didn't sit
right Ellie you know I was sitting there
thinking myself I think this this
chick's lying to me she doesn't have a
bike she's just doing this to try to
look cool to sort of size things up uh
you know maybe even to compete with me
and I was filling up my car one day with
gas and I thought to myself okay well
the tank on my motorcycles uh I think
was 20 liters
so it costs like five or six bucks to
fill up at the time and after I filled
up the uh the bike I said to her by the
way how much does it cost you to fill up
your bike with gas and she said 20 bucks
and I said there's no motorcycle on the
market that has a tank big enough for
you to put 20 dollars worth of fuel in
it you don't have a bike do you
and then she just broke down in tears
and it's like okay what else did she lie
about she lied about a lot of other
stuff I figured out after that point uh
you do not want a pathological liar in
your life
you know of course it would go both ways
but I think I remember hearing something
about
there's some sort of imperative uh
reason why women lie a lot more than men
like they have to protect themselves or
you know it's more a matter of getting
illusions
thing for them yeah so
yeah so women will tend to lie to
preserve their value because again men
look at women as Beauty sex objects so
they'll lie to preserve that value even
though they don't understand it like
it's why they lie about their Notch
count you know for example they won't
volunteer the what happened in Vegas
stays in Vegas the parties the
threesomes the whatever they don't
volunteer that and it's not like they're
trying to hide it either but all that
they're going to is is what makes sense
so women will lie to preserve their
value men will lie to accentuate their
value that's why when guys are on dating
apps you know they'll say six foot if
they're five foot ten that's why when
they're on dating apps they'll uh try to
portray or hold out to the public that
they're successful and Wealthy because
they inherently know that women like
that so they'll take pictures around
super cars they'll take pictures around
interesting places that they travel to
sort of thing
um so that's how men and women lie
differently
right uh just on the topic of
pathological lies
like you pointed out just look out for
little lies it's the little lies that
lead to the big lies like why did you
lie about that silly little thing like
it wouldn't have made a difference if
you told me the truth and if you see
those that's breadcrumbs showing here
yeah what do they say you know how you
do one thing is how you do everything
sort of thing
um I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out